we're reviewing nvidia's rtx 3080
founders edition card today with all of
our new testing methods that we showed
in a video previously
including pressure analysis acoustics
game benchmarks and more
and all that in place we also have
separate upcoming videos with schlieren
photography
of how the cooler performs with regards
to the air movement around it
but we can show a short clip of that
here as a preview more on that soon
these cards are so complex especially
thermally
that we're gonna have a lot of follow-up
pieces for this one and it was difficult
to figure out
what to focus on for the review so the
review is looking at of course game
benchmarks both for rasterized
and for various implementations of ray
tracing hybrid
and full on path tracing we'll be
looking at
thermals in the basics acoustics
pressure
power cold plate flatness stuff like
that and we also have a separate piece
going up on a tear down of the rtx 30
that'll go up today as well and a quick
note that all the testing was done prior
to the teardown as always
then we'll have more for pcie generation
results and a follow-up piece
also but rest assured that we chose the
fastest platform out of all of them that
we tested
for this review today let's get into it
before that this video is brought to you
by
us and the gn store for our 1 million
subscribers limited edition foil t-shirt
the front has the gn logo and a gold
play button like the ones youtube sends
out
and the back has our history on youtube
dating back over a decade
the shirt is custom made with a high
quality 100 cotton and features a shiny
gold foil
one million crept up on us way faster
than expected so these shirts are still
in production
but you can guarantee you'll get one by
back ordering on store.gamersnexus.net
our previous limited shirts have sold
out in just three to four weeks each
time
and like those previous shirts we'll be
using the funding from our one million
subs special shirt to purchase new
testing equipment for our reviews
back order the limited 1 million sub
shirt on store.gamersnexus.net
so again there's a lot we can do with
this card because just the cooler alone
is very unique and warrants a whole lot
of research pieces beyond
the silicon quality review where we're
looking at standard performance for
things like gaming and the thermal
benchmarks will
get very complicated very quickly so
we'll have separate content
but today we do look at some of the
basics of the thermals what's important
to know about it
uh overview for the card it's 700 for
the baseline model there will be partner
cards launching tomorrow the day after
the video goes live
and those cards will be your standard
cooling setups
but there are more advanced ones coming
out after those the partners had a
limited amount of time
to turn around their cooling solutions
for the rtx 3000 series
and so you'll see more rolling out over
the next few months a couple of things
worth addressing separately for the full
specs we have another video on it but
we'll pop up a short
chart for the basics of it if you want
more detail on the architecture we also
have
a an ampere architecture video that's a
full deep dive on it
and then we've got a separate a third
video on our testing methodology if
you're curious how any of this testing
is done you can check those links
in the description below and four key
points that people kept bringing up over
the last month or so ram capacity is one
that everybody was worried about
everyone was extremely concerned it
seemed like in
forums reddit twitter everything about
how much
video memory the rtx 3080 has
because that 10 gigabytes which is
technically a reduction but
first of all as a reminder video memory
was never really the limiting factor
so a lot of people look at gpuz or
afterburner or whatever software
and they see memory allocation or
vram in use and jump to the conclusion
that
if you plug in a 12 gigabyte video card
11 gigabyte 1080 ti
and you go play call of duty and it says
it's using 10 gigabytes or 11 gigabytes
of memory
they then think that 10 on the 3080
isn't enough
so first of all that number that you see
in software that's not
memory and use that's memory allocation
that means that the game is asking for
all this memory to be assigned to it but
it's not necessarily actually doing
anything with it
and so that number is misleading and not
accurate to the actual
memory consumption when you're using
that application you would need separate
software to test that
or some engine level debug software
so want to address that first we've said
that before but it's been a little while
another thing
also is that typically you're bound by
bandwidth
which gddr6x should be solving here or
by things like rops
and not really the capacity but we'll go
through all that in the benchmark
numbers
and then finally the power limitations
were the biggest ones we ran into while
benchmarking this
that's where partner cards will
potentially shine for overclocking and
we'll be talking about that in this
review as well
okay so we're gonna get started there
are time stamps in the description below
if you'd like to jump around
obviously we'd encourage you to not try
and summarize only one part of the video
when you write a comment somewhere else
because it will mislead people and
misrepresent the data so watch the whole
thing if you want to do that
but there are time stamps to make it
easier let's get started we're going to
start this review with thermals
acoustics and the cooler since that's a
huge point for this founder's edition
design
the teardown will be done in a separate
video filmed prior to this review
and it will go live later today so make
sure you check back for that
let's start with a look at the pressure
map for the cooler a flat and flush cold
plate is key to good thermal performance
it doesn't matter how good a cooler is
if you can't get it to mount flush with
the silicon that it's cooling
we tried a few different pressure ranges
for testing but ultimately settled on
this image as the best representation
for cooler contact
we took four total pressure images and
they were almost completely consistent
each time nvidia provided us a mounting
pressure spec of two to two and a half
inch pounds of force which we verified
with
a torque driver prior to disassembly as
well so
we stuck to that same range during
reassembly for pressure testing that way
it represents the factory assembly
in this image you can see that there are
three key areas of improvement
but this is still better than we've seen
for any other reference design we've
tested either from amd
or nvidia the three areas are circular
in shape which we can illustrate here
typically the vapor chamber columns
apply more pressure to the silicon
than the areas devoid of columns but it
depends on how the vapor chamber was
formed it's possible that the columns
are crimped slightly inwards but we'd
need a higher sample size to really know
and we'd probably have to cut it open we
actually made a vapor chamber at cooler
masters factory under its guidance
previously
and part of the approach involves a
sintered powder for conduction
and a column of copper rings to give it
strength and improves performance
you can see that in this factory clip
where a tool is used
to align the vapor chamber underside
with holes for the columns which are
poured in
and shuffled into place nvidia's
founder's edition contact plate has room
for improvement
but it remains one of the better
solutions we've seen for a vapor chamber
vapor chambers are inherently harder to
get flat
than traditional cold plates and heat
pipes anyway and there's a trade-off for
better performance
as a reminder the pressure testing isn't
an illustration of the height of the
cooler just the pressure
in different areas we have a different
task for height and flatness of the cold
plate
this chart uses a specialized depth
testing tool
that measures from a known zero point on
the tool
against the cold plate we spot tested
about 40 locations on the contact area
of the plate
for depth in microns ideally this would
be highly consistent for best contact
the rtx 3080 fe had a minimum depth
measurement of 14 microns
and a maximum of 62 with its median
around 41.
the results aren't terrible for the fe
we've seen a lot worse in cpu coolers
but
we really need to test some other rtx 30
cards for perspective as to if this
result
is actually good or not in the
comparative sense so
we still need to get more data for that
thus far the results are worse than the
cold plate and heat pipe solutions but
that's expected for a vapor chamber
that doesn't mean it's a worse cooler
necessarily because there is that
trade-off
and we'll have to do actual thermal
testing for other 30 cards to find out
the 2080 ti strix
and ftw3 coolers are significantly more
consistent in cold plate flatness
with medians at 29 and 34 microns
respectively
the range is also reduced improving dye
wide consistency for thermals
the kin pin icon ln2 pot was also lying
around so we tested that
it's similar in medium flatness to the
ftw3 fittingly so
but is more consistent in its range than
the f23 or the fe cards
let's look at frequency then thermals
and noise and then games after that and
again timestamps are below if you need
them
for frequency logging we observed an
initial peak frequency of 1980 megahertz
with gpu boost scaling that down quickly
to 1950 megahertz and then again to
about 1920 to 1930
over the course of the test once it hit
steady state like previous nvidia gpus
every 5 to 10 degrees lower will grant
you a frequency bump
in the range of 10 to 25 megahertz
depending on where you are on the scale
remember that
temperature isn't just some fire strike
number that comes out
it's entirely predicated on fan speed
which itself is contingent upon v
bios thermal targets for the core in
other words the fans only spin at a
given speed to maintain a simple
temperature target in firmware
programming
here it seems that nvidia has configured
the fe card to stay within the range of
75 degrees celsius our ambient
temperature for testing was about 21
degrees here
celsius and we'll need rpm and acoustics
for a full picture here's the same
workload but with fan rpm plotted
against thermals at around 800 seconds
in the test you can see a slight 1 to 2
degree blip in gpu thermals
that's then quickly negated that's
because the fan speed ramps here
with relatively low hysteresis in the v
bios the fans respond pretty quickly
they end up settling around 1900 rpm to
maintain 75 degrees in this scenario
but that will change quickly with any
user-defined temperature targets
or extraneous considerations like poor
ventilation if you don't follow
our case buying advice in this test the
fans are about the same speed
but we noticed some other scenarios
where they ramp asynchronously
in order to minimize harmonics caused at
certain rpm ranges like
around 3000 for example here's some
obscenely cool data that we've just
started collecting for gpus this time
you probably won't see this stuff many
other places
this looks at the decibel level for the
cart volume
under a ramping workload to 100 gpu load
similar to what a game would do
in this scenario you can see our noise
floor is around 26 to 27 db with no load
present
and there are no fans on the system
other than the gpu the card ramps to
about 32 to 33 dba under initial load
and once the gpu temperature starts
getting above 60 degrees celsius
we see a more rapid ramp as it tries to
control temperature
this is present around the 70 second
mark here where it ramps and then backs
off temporarily
and then ramps again this also follows
the load scenario for
the software typically we find that a
change in noise of about 3 dba is the
most noticeable
to a user while anything within that
range from current reading is
imperceptible to people who aren't
focusing strictly on noise
the end ramp is around 41.8 dba in this
instance
and that's just because that's where it
starts to maintain the temperature
target
and v bios we'll get a number for rpm in
a second though
the hysteresis appears relatively low on
this fev bios so ramp is overall fairly
quick except for a few places where we
see a gradual climb
once the temperature is more under
control here's the noise level at given
points along the fan speeds the fan rpm
bottoms out at about 1000 rpm on each
fan
due to slight asynchronicity of the fans
to mitigate harmonics we've
averaged the two fans against the
horizontal axis the noise starts at
around 32.6 dba in our test environment
and at this distance
with 40 dba around 1880 rpm for our
testing
that's the number we'll use for noise
normalized thermal comparisons versus
partner model 3080s in the next few days
without some form of noise normalization
you don't get a useful depiction of
cooler
efficacy at 100 speed which was only
ever encountered when manually
configured
we hit 57.6 dba and we'll have a
separate content piece on thermals
versus ram temperature
sea view temperature and cooler
performance case thermals and case
configuration
and impact of cooling in various cases
and things of that nature but that will
be follow-up content along with our
schlieren imaging which will give you a
preview of the card here
but that'll be a separate piece as well
so make sure you subscribe to catch
those
and now it's time to move on to game
testing we'll start off with red dead
redemption 2 with dx12
scaling in vulcan is similar at 4k and
with custom high settings the rtx 3080
fe establishes an
fps average baseline with lows at 67 fps
one percent
and 58 fps 0.1 percent overclocking
didn't get as much as we were power
limited with the default nvidia v bios
but this is where partner cards could
potentially shine we gained about six
percent from the overclock overall
and the 3080 fe leads the 2080 ti strict
stock card 67.8 fps average results by
25 and a half percent
it leads the 2080 super stocks at 54 fps
average result by 58
the 2070 super by about 77 and it's
about
90 ahead of the 1080 ti as for the 5700
xt which is the only real amd part
currently sold that's anywhere close to
this
that's at 47 fps average and about half
the performance of the 3080 fe here's
1440p
when we tested a second ago at 4k the
3080 held a lead over the 2080 ti
of 25 and a half percent but here that
lead drops to 20.6
the 3080s 127 fps average allowed the
overclock
gain of just 3.1 percent here halved
from before
the clocks don't help as much at this
lower resolution
and so leadership versus the 1080 ti ftw
3 stock
is 80 down from 90 at 4k versus the 2080
super the 3080 stock leads by 48
as opposed to 58 previously and things
overall are trending down at lower
resolutions
so keep that in mind if you're not
running 4k the 5700 xt runs 78 fps
average here allowing the 30 80 a lead
of 63
but it's not like 5700 xt competes at
the same price class
anyway it's just that amd hasn't given
us much else to show
at 1080p the 3080 ran 152 fps average
with some room to scale shown by the oc
at 157
that's not a worthwhile oc but it does
show that we're not fully capped when
stuck
this game is largely gpu bound overall
and so the drop in
lead for the 38 over the predecessors is
just because of the architectural
differences
not because of strictly a cpu limit the
3080 leads the 2080 ti by 18
down from 25 at 4k it leaves a 1080 ti
by 71
down from 90 at 4k as well very quickly
here's a vulcan versus dx12 charge for
red dead 2.
this is showing percent improvement with
vulcan versus the x12
if you see a negative number that means
dx12 ran better than vulcan on that
device
this is often within error but it
depends on which one you're looking at
these percentages are purely
self-referential for each card
and have no relation to the other cards
on the chart the 3080 fe stock had an 8
improvement against itself with the x12
or 10
when overclocked the frequency mattered
more the 2080 ti
saw almost the same type of scaling
vulcan appears more sensitive to clock
increases in this game
with those gpus interestingly however
the pascal generation we can highlight
the 1080ti
and non-ti entries and the 5700xt
all show no real change between the set
of them rainbow six siege is new to our
bench and is next run with dx11
at 4k and with ultra settings the rtx
3080 ran at 179 fps average
or 2.7 percent higher with an overclock
the 2080 ti strix ran 144fps average
stock with a much bigger 12
gain from an overclock oc versus oc the
3080 leads by 14
or 24 when stock the lead against the
114 fps average 2080 super is 58
or again about 90 versus the 1080 ti at
94 fps average here
the 5700 xt is around the same spot and
that's for one of the highest
pre-overclocked models you can currently
get
frame times scale evenly with averages
in this game and let's look at a source
of that huge
0.1 percent low dip for the overclock in
the 3080 here's the frame time plot as
always lower is better but more
consistent is best
with the oc line you'll see significant
excursions from the mean several times
throughout this test
and that's because of the overclock
being slightly unstable
unlike how it appears in other game
benchmarks like most overclocks this
isn't a universally good oc
the stock result is much flatter with
matching bounces in the first 1500
frames
and still being an overall better
experience as we get on further in the
benchmark plus those early bounces
aren't high enough to be really
noticeable to the player overclocking on
the 3080fe isn't great but maybe a
higher power limit model will be better
1440p had the 3080 at 329 fps average
the 2080 ti at 271 the 1080 ti at 187
and the 5700 xt at 185. that establishes
a reduced 21
lead over the 2080 ti 76 lead over the
1080 ti
and that's down from again ninety
percent at 4k for that one briefly
here's 1080p the 3080 oc is still
unstable shown here in 0.1 lows and
therefore not a good oc for this game
the stock results runs 431 fps
average 10 over the 2080 ti and 50 over
the 1080 ti ftw fdw3
that said we're clearly also hitting cpu
limits at some point here and that's
since we're only at 1080p the 5700xd
offers similar performance to the 2070
super and the radeon 7 gets left behind
by amd's 5700 from four months later
shadow of the tomb raider at 4k as next
and has the 3080 fe
at 92 fps average with an overclock
proving stable but pointless
the lead over the 2080 tioc is minimal
at 13 compared to previous tests
and so panic selling 2080 ti for 500 is
probably not the best idea
when you could spend a few minutes
overclocking it and getting pretty close
the lead over stock is 25
though that's consistent with previous
results at this point we've established
an obvious trend
we're 25 over the 2080 ti 73
over the 2080 super stock and similar
for the 5700 xt
and 82 over the 1080 ti here we won't
discuss each game in as much detail
going forward now that we've established
the trend at 1440p
the 3080 runs 23 faster than the 2080 ti
faster or higher fps than the 1080 ti
and the 5700 xt and 47
ahead of the 2080 super next chart 1080p
is cpu bound
this is clear for a few reasons like
identical performance between the oc
2080 ti and the stock 3080 but also
because of the dropped lows on cars
bouncing off the cpu bike
this chart is useless for comparison
here for gpus aside from maybe showing
you
that you shouldn't bypass the
capabilities of your cpu
or your intended resolution for gaming
we'll keep this one short this is
microsoft flight sim at 4k
high in our gpu methodology piece we
showed how flight sim isn't scaling very
well for gpu reviews
using our current settings that's
because we became bound by a single
thread
hard at 1080p and at 1440p
at 4k we're not cpu bound yet anyway the
3080 leads the 2080 ti by about 20
percent here
it leads to 2080 super by about 46
percent and the 1080 ti by about 60
percent
the 5700 xd is close to the original gtx
1080 ftw
both of which are doubled by the new
card this is where we would show f1 2019
but the game currently hates the rtx
and we had constant crashing issues or
failure to launch for this reason it's
been removed from the charts here
and gets a did not finish score or a
failure it may work with f1 2020. we
haven't tested that yet here's horizon
zero dawn at 4k
this one has the rtx 380c scaling six
percent over the baseline 87fps average
results but again dropping some of the
frame time consistency
the 2080 ti oc's 74fps howard result
illustrates that you can get close-ish
to 3080 performance with a little bit of
work while baseline allows the 3080 a
more impressive 30 lead than in the
previous tests
the 2080 super is led by 61 the 1080 ti
is led by 78
here and that's less than in some of the
previous titles at 1440p
the 38doc lead is reduced to 4.6
the 2080ti lead remains about 28 and the
1080ti lead is reduced to
68 we're going to quickly flash through
the next few games
pause if you care about any of them in
particular the percent scaling
is similar for all of them and at this
point it's a waste of everyone's time to
talk through the remaining five
rasterized games
at three resolutions each that we tested
just because we've already established a
predictable pattern the hierarchy
remains the same across the stack plus
or minus a few percentage points we'd
rather spend more air time on the
interesting tests like the thermals
earlier in the review instead we'll
quickly go through some rtx results now
mostly useful for those of you who
purchased
20 series cards and actually care to use
rtx features
we aren't putting as much focus on this
right now as it's still not a primary
usage mode for the cards
but this information will be enough to
get you the comparisons we'll start with
minecraft rtx although the most
interesting gains come in quake later on
the 3080 ran 87 fps average leading the
2080 ti's at 65 fps average by 36
percent
that's a larger gap than we saw in the
rasterization only games
up from 25 to 30 previously the lows are
also significantly improved
disproportionately leaning positive on
the 3080.
the 2080 super stock is led by 75 here
with the 2080 fe led by 82 percent a few
lower end cards are also present if you
care about those and as for dlss it's on
for all cards for this game
since minecraft benefits from being
visually predictable enough
that dlss doesn't detract from the
experience at 1440p
the 3080 runs 130fps average leading the
2080 ti strix by 32 percent
still above previous averages the 2080
super and 2080 fe
are near one another led by a split
difference of about 71
at 1080p the 3080 fe gains to 163 fps
average and sadly this is the highest
we've ever seen in minecraft rtx
it's still leading the 2080 ti by 34
percent the 2080 super is led by about
so there's stagnation in the game versus
the ti and the super in terms of the
difference
control is next tested with max rtx and
dlss on
but also briefly with the lss off for
point of comparison
at 4k and with dlss on the 3080 runs at
65 fps
average with lows consistently behind
the rtx 2080 ti runs 49 fps average
allowing the 3080 a 32 lead the 2080
super and below
are all under 40 fps average for
perspective here it is with the lss off
the game becomes
mostly unplayable at true actual 4k
without dlss
so we're only really flashing this
through to provide perspective for what
it does
at 1440p the 3080 runs 111 fps average
28 ahead of the 2080 ti strix and about
63 percent ahead of the 2080 super and
fe
quake 2 is next and this one is
interesting it's not quite there yet at
4k for playability
but the interesting part is that the
3080 leads even harder than it did
previously
it's now at 45 percent higher average
frame rate than the 2080 ti
or 90 ahead of the 2080 supercard which
is insane
the game is path traced so the
difference in rt generations becomes
more apparent
there's more reliance on the hardware in
this specific title 1440p
sees a slight reduction in lead because
we're stepping away from the memory
bandwidth advantages afforded to the
but there's still a significant lead and
we're going to stop here for games
overall we
have enough of them we also have tomb
raider and 1080p results but there's too
much other stuff to talk about
power testing is next for over a year
now our gpu power test methodology has
involved taking both
pcie cable draw and pcie slot draw
with custom measurement tools that we
built we've now added pcat as well for
further validation
this is not total system power
consumption and is instead total card
power
starting with firmware power virus tests
the rtx 3080 stock gpu consumed 323
watts total card draw
ahead of the 2080 oc by about 30 to 40
watts the efficiency
is way up here despite power consumption
also being up
for instance the 1080 ti consumed 325
watts when overclocked
and yet the 3080 stock card was
routinely in the
70 to 90 uplift range versus this card
even overclocked
the 2080 ti pulled the 264 watts stock
and 330 watts overclocked for comparison
with the 2080 fe stock at 235 watts with
that 330 watt oc number on the 2080 ti
the 3080 was often still 10 to 15 ahead
of the 2080 ti oc while being a few
watts lower proving its efficiency
improvements
to get the actual two times performance
per watt number that was marketed
you'd have to power them artificially to
about 240 watts so you'd be power
limiting so that the scale widens
because it converges towards the mean as
power increases
on the 3080 but it's still better though
total war three kingdoms at ultra
is next where these high end cards
struggle to hit even 60 fps at 4k
the 3080 fe overclocks draws 367 watts
here
proving exceptionally inefficient and a
waste of time as compared to its stock
setting
this is particularly thanks to a lack in
gains
for the games we tested but that's
because of power limits as well
so partner models will definitely not
improve the efficiency but might improve
the
amount you gain if we can break through
the wall because the power limit is
pretty limited
on the stock cart the 3080 stock pulled
314 to 320 watts
with the 2080 ti strix oc at 306 to 331.
that's a lot of power to allow a 13
lead to the 3080 stock the 1080 ti stock
card was closer to 283 illustrating how
much more is being done per watt with
this generation
the other two games we tested reflect
these results so we'll skip them
finally here's an overclock stepping
chart from our process of overclocking
the 3080 fe cart
this is all rough note taking with the
intention of quickly establishing a
stable overclock
we most commonly ran into power limits
so shunt resistor mods may help here
we also observed a regression and
performance with the 100 megahertz core
offset and 900 megahertz memory for
our clocks listed it fell below stock
for performance when we applied these
and so they were invalid overclocks you
always have to validate your performance
before fully committing to an oc our
final setting was 90 megahertz core and
700 megahertz memory
along the way we observed a frequency
regression of about 20 to 30 megahertz
from a 10 degree increase in temperature
with no other changes other than auto
fan changes and we also observed a
maximum frequency of 2085 megahertz when
at 60 degrees celsius with those
overclocks applied unfortunately this
wasn't stable for long-term
use and also required a 100 fan speed
but that would at least give you
relative positioning of
where the potentially higher end models
can perform like maybe
hybrid or liquid cooled models or things
that have a higher power limit
especially
so we'll be looking at those in separate
content uh all right
as far as the card overall the cooling
solution has absolutely significantly
improved over
mv's own previous designs they've really
done a lot here and this is stuff we'll
talk about in the teardown as well
but the biggest thing that changed was
an
adequate usage of screws as opposed to
an overkill usage of screws
the next biggest thing that was changed
was nvidia took
the the composite weight of all 70 plus
screws that they used in the original
2080 and removed
and turned it into fins that actually do
things so there is
no wasted space on the card in terms of
functionality they are trying to make
full usage out of the space available
to cool the product and that's a good
thing the partners
are doing kind of a standard approach
for their coolers but because a lot of
them are tri-axial
because a lot of them have taller pcbs
or at least taller coolers on top of the
reference provided pcb
you're still going to see potential for
better performance or
better acoustics or potentially the same
performance
thermally but higher power limits and
that's where comparing coolers
as you see reviews come out of partner
models keep in mind that it's difficult
to compare two coolers which have
different power limits
and also potentially different noise
profiles so
as a tester you really need to dial all
that stuff in to eliminate variables
wherever possible and do a proper
comparison of efficiency so that's stuff
to watch out for performance wise
it depended on the resolution we were in
memory bandwidth is absolutely helping a
lot here
so 19 gigabits per second baseline
overclocking does a little bit
for the most part though overclocking
was not particularly worth it with the
founders edition card that we tested
that may change with other ones or with
other environment variables removed in
the future
for performance baseline and 4k we're on
average seeing some of the 80s to 90
percent improvement over the 1080 ti
absolutely massive change that's not
very common to see that kind of
it's not quite a generational leap it's
a two generational leap that's still a
lot
so big change there as you go down in
resolution
the improvement also goes down so you'll
see that number go down to
say 70 over the scale of 1440 1080 what
have you
that's not just because of cpu
bottlenecks even at 1440p
and gpu bound scenarios like in some of
the games we tested there's still a big
reduction in performance improvement
it's a weird way to phrase it but
the performance improvement is still
large it's just not 90
anymore and a lot of that comes down to
bandwidth and to rops as well if you
start running games let's say
higher anti-aliasing settings you run
full tap msaa
then the rops may assist you there as
well and there's a change in
in the rops in ga 102 and
the other ampere devices which we talked
about in our architecture video
improvement versus the 2080 ti was
anywhere from 20 to 29 percent
in rasterization typically it was about
24 25
at 4k so these are all numbers at 4k
that reduces again as you approach
1440 1080 even in gpu bound scenarios
for those
resolutions and the most interesting
finding here
with regard to performance versus the
2080 ti was actually in ray trace in
applications so with hybrid rendering
where you use rasterization
and rtx the difference wasn't that
extreme
versus the rasterized difference where
we would see again about 25
of 4k it moved up a little bit so to 30
to 34
which is absolutely a benefit of the
newer generation of rt cores discussed
in the architecture video
but the biggest change was in quake 2
and to some extent minecraft
and quake 2 rtx is path traced
everything is rendered with uh with path
tracing as opposed to a hybrid approach
or at least most of everything as far as
i'm aware currently and
it moving the uh the rendering into
entirely ray tracing or almost entirely
radiation the more
heavily you lean on rt cores
the larger the delta between the touring
20 series and the 30 ampere series will
become
so that moved up to something like 45 as
you saw in one of those charts
and obviously go look at the charts if
you just skipped here to get these
numbers then you're not getting the full
picture but
those are the most interesting points
out of all this thermally there's a lot
more work to do
we're gonna be playing around with the
cpu and ram temperatures pursuant to the
orientation of the card stuff like that
there's been a lot of requests we've
heard them
but to do it properly is going to take a
certain amount of time so we'll work on
it
check back for more check back for the
teardown later today the card
performance overall
is uh impressive that's it's a big
recovery from the 20 series
when we reviewed it and called like
three of the cards uh
a waste of our time because they were
basically 1080 ti's and then complained
piteously for 55 days about how there
was no rtx and the cards were named rtx
so this is a big turnaround for nvidia
as for whether you should buy well
it's always the same don't don't just
buy because it's better and shiny
you should buy because you actually feel
like your current system is no longer
serving your needs
if you can stretch out a 1080 ti or a
980 ti for longer
you should absolutely do it economically
and just because it reduces the
amount of waste but if you do really
need a new system because you have a
super old one
or you're no longer happy with the
performance and it's not doing
what you need then the 3080 thus far
seems well positioned that said partner
models are launching
basically immediately and it's probably
worth checking on performance for those
and then amd's got stuff coming up as
well which we'll pay attention to as
soon as there's more info to go off of
that's it for this one thanks for
watching you can help us out directly
with expanding our testing methods like
we did for this review
by going to store.gamersnexus.net and
pre-ordering one of our new shirts or
picking up
a modmat toolkit mouse mat or other item
on the store you can also go to
patreon.comgamersnexus subscribe for
more thanks for watching
we'll see you all next time
the